-Et
quand nos regrets
viendront danser
autour de nous,
nous rendre fous,
seras-tu là ?
Pour
nos souvenirs
et nos amours
inoubliables,
inconsolables,
seras-tu là ?
Pourras-tu suivre
là où je vais ?
Sauras-tu vivre
le plus mauvais ?
La solitude, le temps qui passe
et l'habitude,
regardes-les.
Nos ennemis,
dis-moi que oui.
Dis-moi que oui.
Quand nos secrets
n'auront plus cours,
et quand les jours
auront passé,
seras-tu là ?
Pour,
pour nos soupirs
sur le passé
que l'on voulait,
que l'ont rêvait,
seras-tu là ?
...
Le plus mauvais,
la solitude,
le temps qui passe
et l'habitude,
regardes-les.
Nos ennemis,
dis-moi que oui.
Dis-moi que oui.
La, la, la, la.
Seras-tu là ?